Speaker 1: Hey, you're going to love this.
And Oann host Brutally Attacks Me Tags the
wrong David Pakman on Instagram tagging a
scam account, misspells my name and is generally
totally triggered.
Here's the back story of this.
A few weeks ago, I did a story about O.J.
and host Allison Steinberg.
Allison Steinberg had a conspiracy theory
about her nest thermostat.
I guess she rents an apartment.
She moved into the apartment.
There was a Nest thermostat, which, like every
nest thermostat knows when you walk by, she
calls it, it's tracking her in her home.
And she presented all sorts of unproven conspiracy
theories.
I did a segment on it.
Okay.
So that was the video that I did.
We just showed you a screenshot of it.
So Alison Steinberg is furious with me and
she now has done a segment on Oann.
Imagine that this is Trump's darling Oann
attacking me.
You'll notice my name isn't even spelled correctly
on the entire thing.
Let's get into it.
And what's sad is she's so confused about
these thermostats.
She doesn't understand how they work.
Take a look at this.
I think you're going to like.
Speaker 4: This is a nest thermostat installed,
which I didn't really think much of until
I notice it just started adjusting the temperature
when I wasn't home.
Speaker 1: Now that's a feature you can turn
on and off.
Okay.
I've had nest thermostats for a year there.
There's a learning option where you go, Hey,
pay attention to my activity and whether I'm
home, which it knows by whether you walk by
in front of the thermostat.
And adjust for maximum efficiency, lower the
temperature or allow it to go up depending
on whether it's winter or summer.
This is just a feature.
You can turn it on and off.
Speaker 4: When I realize this device has
the ability to actually sense your whereabouts
immediately led me to believe that this is
yet another system that will soon be required
in probably every new home that's built, which
I personally find deeply disturbing.
Speaker 1: Now it's just homesense.
That's what it's called.
You can tell it sense when I'm home or not.
You can turn it off.
It's no big deal.
Speaker 4: And it was then that I made this
video expressing my concerns over the technology.
But instead of playing you my video, I'm just
going to go ahead and show you a video of
my video.
That's right.
David Pakman a soy infused trigger leftist
soy.
And what I had to say about, you know.
Speaker 1: What's funny is I don't really
eat soy.
I mean, every once in a while I have, you
know, like mapo tofu.
But where is this soy thing coming from?
Speaker 4: Bart Thermostats.
Tracking you was so preposterous.
Speaker 1: It was preposterous that.
Speaker 4: He made a whole video making fun
of me for thinking that globalists were tracking
me.
Watch.
Oh, and please, while you're watching, make
note of his extremely and utterly pathetic
attempt at an Alex Jones impression.
Speaker 1: Ah, yeah.
Okay.
So then she plays my entire clip, which we're
going to skip over because you already know
my clip.
I'm not going to play her playing my clip.
Okay.
So and then now we get back to her commentary
and you just have to listen to this stuff.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, we get it.
You think I'm a crazy conspiracy theorist?
Tinfoil hat wearing Alex Jones of worshiping
weirdo?
Yes.
Which I actually take as a massive compliment
ever so much.
Speaker 1: But what she's saying, I actually
am all of those things.
Speaker 4: Or to tell you, David, that not
only was Alex Jones right, but so was Alison
Steinberg.
When thousands of Xcel customers in Colorado
tried adjusting their thermostats Tuesday,
they learned they couldn't.
Denver7 consumer investigator Jaclyn Ellen
talked with some of those customers.
Jaclyn They're upset they had no control over
the temp in their own home.
That's right.
And, you know, Excel's is calling this a rare
energy emergency.
And, yes, they took over tens of thousands
of smart thermostats here in Colorado for
the first time.
There was nothing homeowners could do about
it.
Well, shucks.
Speaker 1: Now, Allison Steinberg is so clueless
that she doesn't understand.
That's a voluntary Colorado rewards program.
It's it's not mandatory.
Do you understand what you're signing up for?
Okay.
In Colorado, they had this program where if
you opt in with your smart thermostat, it's
your choice, freedom.
If you opt in to let them a set your temperature
during so-called energy emergencies, you get
a $100 credit and 25 bucks a year.
It's optional.
There's no there's no subterfuge.
People chose to do that.
Are the people too dumb to understand what
they're even signing up for?
That may be the case, but it's not really
a conspiracy.
Speaker 4: What do you know?
Looks like conspiracy theories.
When?
Again?
Now, what do you have to say for yourself,
David?
Speaker 1: I just said it.
This is a program people chose to participate
in.
Speaker 4: I think you owe me an apology,
along with about 22,000 other people.
How many Tallarico tried to crank up the AC?
Speaker 2: I mean, it was 90 out, and it was
right during the peak period.
Speaker 4: That's when he found out he had
no control of his thermostat.
A message from Xcel on his thermostat saying
Temperature locked during an energy emergency.
Speaker 3: And our thermostat was locked in
a 78 or 79.
Speaker 4: It turns out he's not alone.
Excel confirms to contact number seven.
22,000 customers were locked out of their
smart thermostats for hours on Tuesday.
Speaker 1: Because they opted into the program
by choice to get 100 bucks and then 25 a year.
Speaker 3: To me, an emergency means there
is, you know, life, limb or, you know, some
other danger out there, some massive wildfires.
Speaker 4: He says he had no idea locked thermostats
came with that.
And it's not what he signed up for.
Speaker 3: It just doesn't sit right with
us to not be able to control our own.
Speaker 1: It quite literally is what he signed
up for, the X Factor House.
Speaker 4: You see, David, when I say globalists,
I'm not just referring to the top 1% upper
echelons of society.
I'm also talking about all of their minions
who are too dumbed down to figure out what's
going on and are complicit in aiding said
globalists and carrying out and ushering in
their agenda.
Speaker 1: I guess that's me.
Speaker 4: And by agenda I mean creating a
spy state and a social credit system all to
keep you safe.
Can you imagine they sell it as convenience.
Oh, look how cool MREs.
You don't have to worry about remembering
to turn off your air anymore, save money on
your outrageously high energy bills.
Speaker 1: Do you think she's figured out
that these are just settings on her nest and
she can turn all of them.
Speaker 4: Off of Democrats and let her smart
thermostat shut off while you're away?
The same people who are creating the problem
are selling you the solution.
Big tech and private companies are teaming
up to put you in a high tech social credit
score prison.
And it's honestly not even really a conspiracy
at this point.
Now that we have dictators like Governor Greaseball
telling us what we can and can't use our AC
and home appliances.
Speaker 1: And today so she cuts to Gavin
Newsom.
The funny thing is this has nothing to do
with just Democratic governors.
Texas is, you know, Texas has this ERCOT system
where they've decided to isolate their electrical
grid.
And so there's storms in the winter and nobody
has power.
It's crazy what Texas has done.
Texas is energy grid, patriotic, independent,
their energy company.
They did the same thing.
They did the exact same thing.
And we covered it at the time.
Texas largest energy companies say they adjust
some customers thermostats due to grid conditions.
Consumers say they weren't aware they opted
into such a program.
It's the same thing with a Republican governor.
It's user error.
The customers don't know what the hell they're
opting in to.
And she wants to pretend it's global issues.
And Gavin Newsom and Democrats.
It's just user error and people who don't
know what the hell they're doing.
Speaker 2: And tomorrow afternoon, after 4
p.m. in particular for PM, please turn your
thermostat up to 78 degrees or higher and
avoid, to the extent possible, using any really
large appliances.
Speaker 4: Now, since we determined that Alex
Jones is more often than not pretty much always
right.
Speaker 1: Remember, she made fun of me for
saying that she's just an Alex Jones wannabe.
And now this is the third time in the video
she says Alex Jones is right about basically
everything.
Speaker 4: Let's go ahead and take a little
trip back to 2004.
Speaker 1: All right.
So then she goes to a report from Alex Jones.
Let's now get to the final part of this, which
is Allison's advice to me.
Speaker 4: Well, there you have it, folks.
I don't know what more you need to see.
They started cultivating this technology decades
ago, and the creators are literally telling
you exactly what they're doing.
But sure.
Go ahead, David.
Keep drinking your soy and getting your poison
shots and believing everything the media tells
you.
Whatever you do, definitely don't question
anything, ever.
Speaker 1: I'm questioning this.
Speaker 4: But if you do see this video, I
would just like to make a couple of very small
requests.
One.
Please stop uploading my content so you can
monetize it.
Speaker 1: I could say the same to you.
Speaker 4: I believe you owe me some cash
now, along with your apology.
And two, for the love of God, stop playing
your prerecorded soundbites.
Impersonating Alex Jones.
Because, quite frankly, they suck and you
sound nothing like him.
If you're going to make fun of someone, at
least do a decent job.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: Oh, and last thing, your button
up sweater vests have got to go.
Speaker 1: I don't have any button up sweater
vest.
I don't know what she's talking about.
Speaker 4: You're already affiliated with
the party who's in support of maps.
So I would hate for people to think that you're
one of them.
Just saying.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: So, anyway, there is Alison Steinberg.
And by the way, maps is like minor attracted
persons.
It's like a code word for pet pedophile.
Which is it sort of their playbook?
Just call anybody you disagree with a pedophile.
So extraordinarily interesting stuff.
And one other little funny note in her post,
she tags an account called David Pakman Show
Fan with no followers that she thinks is me.
And she couldn't even.
I mean, it's crazy.
Every detail is crazy.
She tagged a spam impersonation account of
me when she uploaded this video.
Scary stuff.
We'll have this clip on our Instagram at David
Pakman show.